now an update on the classified
intelligence documents that found their
way onto the internet after a major leak
as Catherine Herridge reports the
Secretary of Defense made his first
comments on the case yesterday
who had access at that point we we don't
know defense secretary Austin
acknowledged Tuesday the leaked U.S
documents were Exposed on the web
potentially for weeks but he said the
probe led by the FBI is making progress
we will continue to investigate and and
turn over every rock until we find the
source of this and the extent of it two
officials tell CBS News stamps have been
taken to cut down the number of people
receiving some classified briefings as
the investigation accelerates it's
actually easier the higher the level of
classification Robert Anderson worked
counterintelligence and Espionage cases
at the FBI he says the highly classified
nature of the leaked records May create
a short list all those documents are
numbered and accounted for so you can
actually very quickly get to who had
access the leaked records were
apparently printed before being
photographed and posted online a U.S
official says printers used for
classified documents register a unique
ID possibly a clue for investigators
well there's going to be a significant
effort to look at all these different
investigative Avenues in the physical
world and the digital world meanwhile
the bind Administration deals with a
diplomatic Fallout we have engaged with
allies and Partners at high levels over
the uh the past the past days including
to reassure them about our own
commitment to safeguarding intelligence
U.S officials tell CBS news that before
the leak a thousand people or more
potentially had access to the classified
material to limit the risk that number
has now shrunk significantly Tony
all right Catherine thank you very much